catherine barbelsing is the new chair of
the social mobility commission in her
inaugural speech today she said that
britain is too focused on the rags to
rich's dream and people in the poorest
parts of society do not need to aim for
an oxbridge education catherine's also
known as britain's strictest
headmistress leading a school called the
michaela community school in a deprived
area of london her methods are often
seen to be controversial i spoke to her
a short time ago
catherine thanks for joining us on the
show today uh today you set out your
vision for britain and social mobility
or the government's new social
mobilities are but before we get on to
all of that um i wanted to talk to you
about education because for viewers that
don't know you you are branded now as
the country's strictest head teacher i
don't know if you love or loathe that or
just find it a bit
amusing but but let's start off about
talking about uh education there was a
documentary on itv uh about you and your
school
um and at the start of this documentary
one of your colleagues says it's not
like north korea
but those
unused to your beliefs about education
might think it did look a bit like north
korea so can you can you explain to the
viewers why it's not
because the place is just filled with
love you know the children are happy
that staff are happy
the staff love seeing the children
i see them for assembly every single day
in fact i do seven assemblies a week you
know because we've got seven year groups
um
there's just a real sense of purpose we
all know why we're there we're there
because we want to achieve and give the
children skills and knowledge that they
need to be able to make the most of
their lives and to enable social
mobility for our children because we're
in the inner city with children coming
from a variety of different backgrounds
and um we want to give them the best
chances that they can have in life
really and and just
you know if people that haven't seen the
documentary or know about your school i
mean it is really strict so there's no
talking in corridors i think there's a
line along the corridor yeah uh if you
drop your pencil you get a detention uh
well
not if you're not gonna if you were to
not bring your pen in you would get a
detention um you're dropping your pencil
that's fine that's fine but but i'm
trying to get across this it's really
really strict and it's unusually strict
compared perhaps with other uh state
schools why do you do it like that
yeah well the thing about strict is that
people tend to think that must mean that
you're mean but actually i would say
that it means you love the children
enough to keep your standards high for
them so the pen is a good example you
need to bring a pen into school
they're all taught to make sure that
they're packing their bags the night
before they've all got the same pencil
case with the same pens so there's real
consistency and those same pens are
expected for five years so they have two
black pens a blue pen a 2b pencil
they've got and they know exactly what
they need to be in there so
in that sense it's relatively
straightforward but then even if they do
forget it some of the children run a
little shop in the morning where they
sell pens for 10p so you can always pick
up a pen in the morning if you're if
you've forgotten it
and catherine what do you do with kids
that
can't do it or won't do it or do you
believe that it isn't that kids can't do
this
they can't can't adhere to your rules i
mean i mean
they all manage it uh the key thing is
to remember that um children have agency
and they can choose whether or not they
want to do something what do you do with
kids
what do you do with kids with special
education needs or kids with adhd kids
that might not be able
because of their own issues to focus in
the way that you require them to focus
in class do you have separate rules for
them or do those children have to
conform or do they not fit into the
school
well we have a normal intake of inner
city children so we have a variety of
children with different issues i would
say i mean there are a few children you
might need to slightly adapt for but
i would say that too often we allow
labels to force us to lower our
expectations of children um
and that they could achieve a lot more
if we just allowed ourselves to believe
in them despite the fact that they might
struggle so if they struggle in
something you might have to give them
some support in getting there to be able
to meet those standards some children
don't require much support and some
children require more support
um
but the key thing is to believe that
they can do it there has been a sense
from others in the teaching community
that you're kind of implicitly
criticizing uh other teachers or other
schools that do it differently to you
what do you say to that catherine
well if you're you can do things however
much you like as long as you're doing
right by the children i mean what i mean
is uh do you go to the school and visit
and think the children are well behaved
they're learning lots have they got
great gcse results are the children
happy are they loved if that's the case
then brilliant but if that's not the
case
then well we ought to be critical of
those schools shouldn't we i mean
shouldn't we as a society say that's not
good enough come on you've got to do
better now the thing is there are some
schools in genuine difficulty that are
trying very hard to get better and
that's brilliant but there are other
schools that are ideological in their
position that don't want to change
because
they don't believe
that children can do better what do you
mean by the ideological in their
position
well for instance they would find uh our
strict rules um
offensive they don't like that idea
but then if it's pointed out that but
look
there's lots of chaos here in this
school perhaps it would be better if you
had more rules they don't want to do
that and i would be critical of that you
know you spoke at the 2010 conservative
party conference and you became kind of
an emblem if you like of traditional
ways of teaching i mean some of your
fellow teachers make this point about
you when they're asked about you that
you're an excellent teacher clearly with
great ideas to offer
but you have become sometimes like a
weapon in a culture war in which what
you've just said about different methods
of teaching that other parents or
teachers might like somehow you're
critical of those and and that becomes a
culture war
what do you think about that do you do
you
disagree with that or do you not mind or
do you think it's okay
well i think it's
i think that we all need to have high
standards for all of our children and
there are children
right now
in classrooms with very poor behavior
who aren't able to learn and i'm the
chair of the social mobility commission
i believe very much in social mobility
for all of our children and if there are
children who aren't able to be upwardly
mobile because of the poor behavior in
their classrooms then that's something i
need to be critical about in what i've
read about you and what i've seen about
you in terms of your teaching you stress
the importance of adults modelling
standards and behavior for children
that's a really important value for you
do you think the prime minister is a
good role model for children
no i do not think so um
i don't uh
i wish he could be but he isn't um and
that is a bit sad but um
you know
i i can't get into the ins and outs
because i don't know enough about um
you know people say you know will she be
there should he not be there i don't
know you know uh i don't i i like boris
i don't think he's a bad guy you know um
but i don't
i don't know enough about what he's got
up to but i do not think that he's a
good role model for children what's not
good about him in what way
well his personal life for instance
uh
that that does make me sort of raise an
eyebrow um
his hair
how can i say his hair we've got strict
rules at school you know the other day i
saw a picture of him in the metro and i
looked at his hair and i thought oh my
goodness you know we expect our children
to have professional looking hair and i
looked at his hair and i thought gosh i
couldn't put him up on the wall and say
let's all have haircuts like him um now
you might think oh that's a bit pedantic
and that's a bit silly
but it isn't actually i think for our
children um
it's important to
uh look professional
and
sometimes boris looks professional but
sometimes he's not professional enough
for me let me put it that way okay so
family values because that's a small
secret family values exactly it's the
sort of thing that makes me pause a
little bit now and that's not to say
he just you know and actually i'd say
i'm i'm
relatively liberal about these things to
a certain extent you know but he does
kind of push the boat out a bit on that
own character
well and that's where you start and as i
said i don't know the ins and outs
enough about all the recent partygate
stuff you know i just don't know the
details because i'm too busy working to
follow all of that but
but it does sort of make you pause and
go
you know i certainly would never be able
to put him up and say be like him i
couldn't do that
look you just did a speech on social
mobility you talked about a fresh
approach i listened to it and at the
heart of it it seemed to me
that your approach is driven through a
combination of sort of spreading
opportunity more across the country and
an individual's own agency to kind of
change their lives rather than talking
about sort of structures holding people
back and structural inequalities is that
a fair interpretation of what your
approach will be in this job
yeah um
the thing is is that we want to look at
people who are backing the trends how is
it that in an unequal society that some
people are are upwardly mobile what do
they do to achieve that and um
so we want to look at them we also want
to look at uh
the ideas around what happens to the
many as opposed to the few often i think
as a society we are pushed um
to look at the people who start at the
bottom and then zoom to the top and it
makes a great hollywood film
it's romantic it's wonderful look i grew
up with nothing and now i'm this big ceo
and i eat expensive dinners but not all
of us necessarily want to do that and
some of us want to have shorter
mobilities and
it would be wrong for instance someone
comes from a home that's where lots of
unemployment and then they become a
manager at sainsbury's well isn't that
something to celebrate but often we
don't necessarily celebrate these the
these smaller achievements because we
only see the huge leap um as as the
success story and um
we would like to change the narrative
around that really going on to that idea
about the sort of success being defined
as i think you said a sort of
caretaker's daughter ending up in
oxbridge
and it actually being success defined as
someone whose parents are unemployed and
then have been long time unemployed and
then they get a job that that is their
version of social mobility that maybe
oxford is too much but becoming a
manager at sainsbury's is not right and
different people want to do different
things but of course we've got children
at school who are going to oxbridge and
it's really exciting and we're 100
behind that so you don't want to stop
doing that but not everyone can go to
oxbridge that's all but
one thing i did want to ask you though
because i think you went to oxford
didn't you yeah um because when it comes
to oxbridge the the higher education
minister said recently that those
universities shouldn't discriminate
against private school students going to
oxbridge that those organizers tilted
too much and they're too focused on
getting more state school kids in what's
your view of that
yeah i don't know to be honest i don't
know how much they're tilting one way or
the other it is important that um
the
the places that everyone wants to get
into whether it's the big law firms or
it's oxbridge and so on it's important
that they
recognize that they can get talent from
all different types of places and
they're not just coming from the private
sector or they're just not coming from
the state sector so they need to keep an
open mind and that's good but from my
point of view i'm thinking about how can
we make sure it's chair as the
commission how can we make sure as many
people as possible
are enabled to be able to make a success
of their lives finding a career that
they love which will give them purpose
and satisfaction because not all of us
want to be prime minister not always not
all of us want to be millionaires and
that's good i mean you're not prime
minister and you're very happy doing
your job you know
like that's the thing all of us want to
do different things i love being a
teacher i love being at school with the
children so
we all need to do what gives us it makes
us passionate you know what would you
like to do in the future i mean you've
you know you're extremely successful
professional in teaching you've now got
a public sector role advising the
government on social mobility is
politics something you might want to do
one day no never i mean in fact i feel
bad as chatting about boris because at
the end of the day he's just a man and
he's taken on a role that i would never
do and i would never do it because i
wouldn't want people sitting on a on a
television program chatting about me in
this way and yet
in that sense he has sacrificed you know
and given over his life to do that but
if you did do it you could implement
your school model across the entire
country no
no that's the thing you need to win
people's hearts and minds you can't do
that in fact in many ways you're very
powerless as prime minister um
i think we misunderstand just how much
power our prime minister actually has
catherine thank you so much that was
fascinating thanks for coming on thank
you